THE SENATE COMMITTEE HEARING IS
NOW IN ORDER. WE HAVE. GOOD
MORNING. EVERYBODY TODAY WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH,
FILE ITEM ONE, SB 1419, BY
SENATOR RUBIO. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION WHEN
YOU ARE READY. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. THANK YOU. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, SB
1419, WHICH I'M PRESENTING HERE
TODAY, WILL ESTABLISH THE FOOD
DESERT ELIMINATION ACT OF 2024
TO HELP ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY
AND POVERTY ISSUES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE OR AT RISK
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
THIS BILL WILL AIM TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY, FRESH FOOD OPTIONS. I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MADAM CHAIR, THAT
I WILL BE TAKING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS IN REGARDS TO REMOVING
THE DEADLINE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS AND
PROVIDE LANGUAGE TO ALLOW CDFA
SOME FLEXIBILITY, AND ON
APPROVING SMALLER SCALE GROCERY
STORES. AND THAT WOULD BE IN THE
NEXT POLICY COMMITTEE, AGAIN,
MEMBERS I COMPARE TO THE REST OF
THE NATION. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LARGEST NUMBER OF SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
SNAP RECIPIENTS. WITH THE
PANDEMIC INCREASING, THOSE
NUMBERS RECENTLY, IN APRIL OF
2023, FOLLOWING RESCINDING OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL SNAP ALLOTMENT,
FOOD INSECURITY SURGED AND BY
OCTOBER 2023, MORE THAN 1 IN 5
FAMILIES BECAME FOOD INSECURE.
FOOD. WHILE FOOD INSECURITY IS
THE INABILITY TO AFFORD
NUTRITIONALLY ADEQUATE AND SAFE
FOOD, IT IS INCLUDE INCLUDES
LIMITED. I'M SORRY, IT'S
UNCERTAIN HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THEIR FOOD. FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO GET THEIR FOOD. AND
ACCORDING TO THE 2022 USDA DATA,
10.5% OF CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS,
4.1 MILLION HOUSEHOLDS, OR 11.8
MILLION RESIDENTS, ARE IN A FOOD
DESERT. SO THIS BILL AIMS TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE THAT FOOD
TO THOSE THAT NEED IT THE MOST,
TODAY WITH ME IS MY WITNESS TO
TESTIFY, LETICIA GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING,
LETICIA, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION HERE AS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB 1419, SB
1419 CREATES THE FOOD DESERT
ELIMINATION ACT, AND IT HELPS TO
ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY BY
CREATING A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WILL ESTABLISH GROCERY STORES
AND FOOD DESERTS, CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA GROCERS REPRESENT
LARGE, REGIONAL, SMALL AND
INDEPENDENT AND INDEPENDENT
GROCERS ALL THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND OUR MEMBERS TAKE
PRIDE IN FEEDING THE COMMUNITY
THEY SERVE, NOT ONLY THROUGH THE
SALE OF GROCERIES, BUT ALSO
THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC EFFORTS
LIKE FOOD DRIVES, EDUCATIONAL
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND DEPENDENTS, AND PARTNERING
WITH LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
NONPROFITS AT CGA, WE'RE
CONSTANTLY BEING ASKED BY LOCAL
AND STATE REPRESENTATIVES, HOW
DO I GET A GROCERY STORE IN MY
DISTRICT? WELL, THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS NOT AS SIMPLE AS 1ST MAY
THINK. GROCERY STORE OPERATORS
MAKE A VERY, VERY LARGE
INVESTMENT INTO OPENING A NEW
GROCERY STORE, AND THEY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT INVESTMENT WILL
THRIVE DEPENDING ON THE LOCATION
SET UP. COSTS FOR GROCERY STORES
RANGE FROM 7 TO $15 MILLION PER
STORE, AND THAT IS EXCLUDING
LABOR COSTS. SB 1419 WILL MAKE A
MODEST INVESTMENT TO BRING A
LONG TIME GROCERY STORE TO
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN NEED.
THERE ARE SUCCESSFUL MODELS THAT
DEMONSTRATE HOW INVESTMENTS INTO
GROCERY STORES HAVE BROUGHT
FRESH FOOD OPTIONS TO
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ONCE WERE
LACKING. PENNSYLVANIA HAS A
FRESH FRUIT FINANCIAL FRESH FOOD
FINANCING INITIATIVE THAT HAS
PROVIDED GRANTS AND LOANS TO
BRING GROCERY RETAILERS TO FOOD
DESERTS. JUST LAST YEAR,
ILLINOIS PASSED THE ILLINOIS'S
GROCERY INITIATIVE, WHICH WILL
HELP PLACE GROCERY STORES IN
FOOD DESERTS THROUGH GRANTS AND
A SUCCESSFUL MODEL IN CALIFORNIA
IS ONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT. THROUGH FRESHWORKS
AND ONE OF OUR HISPANIC GROCER
MEMBERS, NORTHGATE MARKETS.
ACTUALLY, THEY BENEFITED FROM
THAT NORTHGATE PARTNERED WITH
CAL ENDOWMENT TO ESTABLISH THREE
STORES, ONE IN SAN DIEGO, ONE IN
INGLEWOOD AND ONE IN SOUTH LA.
ALL THREE STORES ARE STILL
OPERATING AND PROVIDING THE
OPTION OF FRESH FRUITS TO THE
COMMUNITY. THE ENDOWMENT, LATER
RELEASED A REPORT WHERE THEY
FOUND MANY SHOPPERS REPORTED
THAT THEIR RESPECTIVE NORTHGATE
MARKET IS MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
GRANTS THEM GREATER ACCESS TO
FRESH PRODUCE AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT FOOD COMPARED TO OTHER
STORES. IT HAS BEEN PROVEN THAT
INVESTMENTS TO PLACE GROCERY
STORES IN FOOD DESERTS ARE
SUCCESSFUL. CALIFORNIA HAS YET
TO MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS, AND I
THINK THIS IS THE TIME TO
ADDRESSING FOOD ACCESS AND FOOD
DESERTS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE, AND
ONE IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT
PUZZLE IS ESTABLISHING A FULL
SERVICE GROCERY STORE THAT CAN
BRING A VARIETY OF FRESH FOODS
AND PRODUCE TO A COMMUNITY. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB 1419. THANK YOU.
HAVING HEARD, FROM THE LEAD,
TESTIMONY CAN DO. WE HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN ROOM 112 HERE TO STATE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL?
PLEASE COME ON UP. STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. OKAY.
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? OKAY, OKAY. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT, WHICH IS A
HEARTBREAKING STORY THAT I JUST
HEARD THIS WEEK, ACTUALLY, WITH,
SOME OF THE 99 CENT STORES
CLOSING, FAMILY WAS DISTRESSED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR CANNED FOODS,
WHICH IS SAD. AND THE REASON I
POINT THAT OUT, BECAUSE THIS
REALLY FOCUSES ON BRINGING
ACCESS TO HEALTHY, FRESH FOOD
OPTIONS. AND THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. AT THIS MOMENT,
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED, AND WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE A VOTE THEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY AT
THIS MOMENT, I WILL GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT MY BILL. SO I'M GOING TO
GIVE THE GAVEL OVER. YOU CAN SIT
WHEREVER YOU. YEAH. YEAH,
WHEREVER YOU LIKE, IF YOU WANT
TO. ALL RIGHT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS SB 1448 BY THE CHAIR.
SENATOR, WHO? HURTADO, WHO WILL
PRESENT. MUSICAL CHAIRS, NO PUN
INTENDED. PLAYERS. THAT'S RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING. AND THANK YOU,
PLEASE BEAR WITH ME. I THINK I'M
COMING DOWN HERE WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF, SOMETHING. I DON'T THINK
IT'S CONTAGIOUS, SO DON'T WORRY.
AND IF IT IS, I APOLOGIZE. BUT
ANYWAYS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
1448, A BILL THAT WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO LAND AND MARKETS FOR
SMALL AND UNDERSERVED FARMERS.
ACCESS TO LAND IS A SIGNIFICANT
HURDLE FOR SMALL, UNDERSERVED
AND LIMITED RESOURCES, AS LAND
ACCESS IS MULTIFACETED AND
COMPLEX WITH A COMBINATION OF
HISTORICAL DISCRIMINATION AND
THEFT. PAIRED WITH TODAY'S
INCREASING PRESSURE OF HEDGE
FUNDS AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT
COMPANIES RAPIDLY PURCHASING
AGRICULTURAL LAND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, LOCAL AND REGIONAL
FOOD SUPPLY CHAINS HAVE BEEN
DRASTICALLY UNDERFUNDED AND
UNDER-RESOURCED, LEAVING SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS TO DEVELOP NEW
SUPPLY CHAINS WITH LITTLE TO NO
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO INVEST IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FOR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSFORMATION. THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC REVEALED
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE US FOOD
SYSTEM, REVEALING A SYSTEM ILL
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE DISRUPTION TO
THE COMPLEX. COMPLEX NETWORK OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND. PARDON ME. IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
ADDRESS THESE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
CREATED. THE FARM TO COMMUNITY
FOOD HUBS PROGRAM AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AG. THIS PROGRAM WAS AIMED
TO SUPPORT SMALL AND UNDERSERVED
FARMERS WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURAL
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO FORM NEW
AGGREGATION CENTERS OR FOOD HUBS
TO SELL TO INSTITUTIONAL MARKETS
AND INVESTMENT. NO OTHER CURRENT
CDFA PROGRAM PERFORMS. IN 2022,
THE AGRICULTURAL LAND EQUITY
TASK FORCE, FACILITATED BY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL, WAS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH SB 179. THE
TASK FORCE IS MANDATED TO
DEVELOP A FULL REPORT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE END OF
THREE YEARS. WHAT THEY SAID OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE ON
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE LAND
EQUITY CRISIS. HOWEVER THERE ARE
SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES FOR BOTH PROGRAMS.
WHILE CHARGED WITH ADDRESSING
LAND EQUITY ISSUES, THE TASK
FORCE HAS NOT HAS EQUITY ISSUES
OF ITS OWN. THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL BELIEVES IT IS NOT
AUTHORIZED TO COMPENSATE MEMBERS
OF THE TASK FORCE FOR THE TIME
ON THE COMMITTEE, INCLUDING THE
HISTORICAL OR HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMERS OF COLOR,
AND TWO, THE TASK FORCE ALSO
DOES NOT HAVE ANY TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE THE SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE END OF
THE THREE YEARS ARE POSTED ON
THE SGC WEBSITE. SO THE SOLUTION
HERE, SB 1448, ADDRESSES
ESSENTIAL EQUITY ISSUES FOR TWO
IMPORTANT EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
WOULD IMPLEMENT THE FOLLOWING
REFORMS. CLARIFY TASK FORCE.
FORCE MEMBERS MAY RECEIVE A
REASONABLE PER DIEM USING
EXISTING OR PRIVATE FUNDS,
SIMILAR TO OTHER TASK FORCE AND
COMMITTEES USE. IT WILL ENSURE
THAT AGRICULTURAL LAND EQUITY
TASK FORCE REPORT IS MADE PUBLIC
AND IT STREAMLINES THE FARM TO
COMMUNITY FOOD HUB PROGRAM
ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BEING LESS PRESCRIPTIVE, AND
ALLOWING FOR MEMBERS OF EXISTING
CDFA COMMITTEES TO SERVE AND
EXTEND THE SUNSET FOR THE FARM
TO COMMITTEE FOOD HUB PROGRAM TO
ENSURE IT HAS SUFFICIENT TIME TO
COMPLY WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I HAVE JAMIE LEE AND
I ALWAYS MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME.
LAST NAME FANOUS WITH THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS. AND, SO HERE SHE IS.
YES. THANK YOU. YEAH. JAMIE
FENIUS I ALSO HAVE BROUGHT ALONG
A FARMER WITH ME TODAY. WHO?
I'LL LET HIM INTRODUCE HIMSELF.
AND THEN I WILL GET INTO MY
TESTIMONY. HI. MY NAME IS
NATHANIEL GONZALEZ SIEMENS. WE
HAVE A FARM JUST OUTSIDE OF
BAKERSFIELD, WE FARM SOME
ALMONDS THERE, AND WE'RE
TRANSITIONING THAT OLD ALMOND
FARM INTO A DIVERSITY OF FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES, PRIMARILY TO, AS
A U-PICK TO FEED OUR COMMUNITY,
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE THAT WITHIN
50 MILES, AND IT'S. WE DON'T OWN
THAT LAND. WE'RE HOPING TO BUY
IT SOMEDAY. WE'VE WE'VE LIVED
THERE FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE, AND,
THE LAND PRICES HAVE GONE UP AND
THE LAND ACCESS HAS GONE DOWN,
SO WHEN MELISSA CAME OUT, A FEW
MONTHS AGO, IT WAS REALLY
HEARTENING TO, TO SEE THAT THAT
WE HAD SUPPORT. I MEAN, WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER, BUT IT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT TO, TO HAVE HELP AND HAVE
AN INSTITUTION BEHIND US AND
BEHIND OUR FRIENDS WHO ARE IN
SIMILAR SITUATION. OKAY. THANKS
SO MUCH. THANKS, SO, YEAH. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JAMIE
FANOUS. I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT CAF, THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS. CAF
REPRESENTS AROUND 8000 SMALL AND
MID-SIZED FARMS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, AND HAS WORKED
FOR ABOUT 46 YEARS TO PRESERVE
FAMILY SCALE AGRICULTURE AND
PROMOTE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY. THE SENATOR HAS
COVERED ALL OF THE CORE DETAILS
OF THIS PROGRAM ON THIS BILL AND
THE CORRECTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED,
BUT I'LL JUST NAME A FEW
IMPORTANT STATISTICS AS TO WHY
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT, WE ARE
LOSING 1500 SMALL SCALE FARMS A
YEAR IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CHALLENGE IS FACING SMALL
SCALE FARMERS ARE SIMPLY TOO
OVERWHELMING TO BEAR, FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE TO SUPPLY CHAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES, IT'S
REALLY AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK TO BE
A LOCAL FOOD PRODUCER TODAY,
ULTIMATELY, THESE TWO PROGRAMS
ARE WAYS IN WHICH WE WANT TO
INVEST IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
SMALL SCALE FARMERS AND ACTUALLY
COME UP WITH MEANINGFUL
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE LAND
ACCESS ISSUE FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS. UNLESS YOU ARE A
MILLIONAIRE OR A FOURTH
GENERATION FARMER, GETTING
ACCESS TO LAND IS JUST NOT
POSSIBLE. BEALL IF YOU ARE A
BEGINNING FARMER, IF YOU ARE A
FARMER OF COLOR, YOU NEED A
ENDOWMENT TO KEEP YOU GOING AND
THAT IS JUST NOT GOING TO STAND
ANYMORE UNLESS WE WANT TO KEEP,
LOSING FARMERS IN THE STATE,
THIS THIS BILL IS REALLY CLEAR,
IT IS JUST ADDRESSING SOME
ESSENTIAL ADMINISTRATIVE
CORRECTIONS TO BOTH THE LAND
EQUITY TASK FORCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR UNDERSERVED FARMERS ARE
BEING COMPENSATED FOR HELPING TO
CREATE POLICY SOLUTIONS, AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT EXISTS IN
OTHER TASK FORCES, SO THIS
CORRECTION IS, IS NOT NEW. AS
WELL AS CREATE SOME OF THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT FOOD HUBS PROGRAM
WAS ACTUALLY CREATED, SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND HOPE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL IN THE
HEARING ROOM? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD AND
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT. RIGHT. SO
GOOD TO SEE YOU. I APPRECIATE IT
. I THINK IT'S HI. GOOD MORNING,
MY NAME IS JARED LAWSON. I'M
WITH PI RANCH IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY, AND WE HAVE, ESTABLISHED
A COMMUNITY FOOD HUB, GREW OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC, AND ALSO, FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS, HAVE LAUNCHED
AN INCUBATOR PROGRAM TO HELP
NEXT GENERATION FARMERS, AND
PARTICULARLY WOMEN AND BIPOC
FARMERS, HAVE ACCESS TO LAND,
AND IT'S TEMPORARY. IT'S THEY
HAVE IT'S A FIVE YEAR PROGRAM
AND ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
ISSUES, ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES IN
1448 IS CRITICAL FOR THIS TASK
FORCE TO REALLY DO THE JOB OF
THE POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
HELP OUR PARTICIPANTS IN THIS
PROGRAM. GET TO THE NEXT LEVEL
IN THEIR THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR FOLKS TO JUST SIMPLY STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
INDICATE THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL. WE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. HI. WELCOME. HI.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HART. I'M THE
OWNER AND OPERATOR OF H AND K
FAMILY FARMS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY, AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IT'S ESSENTIAL. THANK YOU. HI.
MY NAME IS WILL HOLLOWAY. I'M A
OWNER OPERATOR OF LONGER TABLE
FARM IN SONOMA COUNTY AND BOARD
CHAIR OF FEED COOPERATIVE AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF 1448. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. I'M ALEXIS
KOFOD AND I'M THE OWNER FARMER
OF SOUL FOOD FARM IN VACAVILLE.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
REINA YAGI. I AM OWNER AND
OPERATOR OF YAGI SISTERS FARM IN
SONOMA COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. HI, I'M EMILY SCHWING. I'M
WITH VEGGIE LUCIAN IN EAST SAN
JOSE AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY, AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. HI, I'M
MARY MAYADAS AND I'M FROM VEGGIE
LUCIAN IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY,
EAST SIDE SAN JOSE, AND I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL? SEEING NONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY, SENATOR. THANK
YOU. THAT WILL BE, PUT ON CALL
UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. I'M
GOING. TO.
ALL RIGHT. IN THE INTERIM, THE
COMMITTEE ON AG WILL STAND IN
RECESS UNTIL WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IS BACK FROM RECESS,
AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SECRETARY,
PLEASE. SENATORS HURTADO HERE,
AUTO HERE. GROVE ALVARADO. GIL.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ HERE. PADILLA.
HERE. PADILLA. HERE OKAY. QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. AND WITH
THAT, WE WILL GO AHEAD AND, CALL
A VOTE FOR THE BILLS THAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE WE NEED A MOTION
FOR WE NEED A MOTION. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB 1419 BY SENATOR
RUBIO? MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THAT.
THE MOTION IS ON FILE ITEM ONE,
SB 1419. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. BUT FIRST WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. SENATORS, HURTADO I,
HURTADO I GROVE. ALVARADO. GIL
CORTEZ CORTEZ I, PADILLA I,
PADILLA I. AND WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AS WELL. AND I OH, SORRY. I'M
STILL A LITTLE SICK. I
APOLOGIZE. THE VOTE WAS, THE
VOTE WAS THREE ZERO, AND THE
BILL IS OUT. AND UP NEXT WILL DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION? MOVE CONSENT. THANK
YOU. AS SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. MOTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CALENDAR FILE ITEMS
TWO AND FOUR, SB 1270 AND 1522.
SENATORS HURTADO, A, HURTADO,
AYE. GROVE. ALVARADO, GIL.
CORTEZ, CORTEZ, AYE. PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. OKAY. THE VOTES
THREE ZERO AND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS ARE ALL OUT AND
UP. NEXT WE HAVE, AND LAST WE
HAVE SENATE BILL 1448. AND DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THAT BILL? I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. AND
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS ON FILE. THE
MOTION IS ON FILE ITEM THREE, SB
1448 BY SENATOR HURTADO.
SENATORS HURTADO AYE. HURTADO
AYE. GROVE ALVARADO. GIL.
CORTEZ. AYE CORTEZ AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PADILLA AYE. OKAY. AND THE
VOTE IS THREE ZERO. AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. AND I BELIEVE THAT
IS IT FOR TODAY. THANK YOU ALL
FOR JOINING US. AND THANK YOU TO
ALL THOSE THAT CAME UP. AND,
PROVIDE A TESTIMONY AT TODAY'S
HEARING. AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
ALL. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH. WITH
THAT, THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IS NOW OVER